imagine 91 billion light years traveled
like that your father is lost in the
universe we believe he is and we're here
to help you find them this is my
favorite plant of the entire galaxy
no offense turn
you're going to be tested
every step of the way
[Music]
the Oreo I trust you
[Music]
oh we go in time rated PG March 9th
close your eyes
see with mine you are a top student but
look at you now you can't keep using
your father's disappearance as an excuse
to act out is that his work what's it
about their dad he wanted to touch the
Stars imagine that the aunt here wants
to get to her another hand as quickest
option is to walk across the street but
it turns out a straight line is not the
shortest distance between two points not
if you use a fifth dimension it's
outside of the rules we know as time and
space aunt arrives my hand instantaneous
so you fall to space more likely weren't
going
[Music]
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find them we are in search of warriors
warriors who serve the good and the
light in the universe you're kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not I'm not your father's trapped by an
evil energy it's too strong for our
light and the only one who can stop it
is you be a warrior
my love is always there even if you
can't see
[Music]
trust me I trust you
[Music]
you
you